so much to talk about but we got to
start with the dog we just have to
because one of the things it was the
first thing that I loved about the dog
and it's still the thing I love the most
about the dog are the eyes I know the
eyes the eyes of the dog I mean dead and
crazy at the same time everything
everything you know the writing has
always been spectacular a lot of writers
help me always the voice was uh always
uh crazy A crazy choice
um we should tell people the origin
story because it came out of this thing
we were doing on the show which was a a
talent show and there was a fake um the
idea was maybe they'll this talent show
and we'll use whatever we have to do all
came out of this
insane like uh directive we created for
the show and that was a mantra that I
drove the writers crazy with which was
just like we're not going to do any
found humor right like I was obsessed
with
we're not going to Copy Dave Letterman
because we worshiped this guy even when
we were at Saturday Night Live we
secretly knew that Dave's show was the
coolest show on TV yeah and as much as I
loved Conan and believed in him I didn't
I just thought nobody can do stuff that
Dave's doing right including remotes
which shows what a shitty producer I was
I was like Conan can't do remotes
because Dave doesn't and I've seen Pat
say Jack do it and Pat s Jack's as good
as Conan and he fail who could follow
sjck yeah if s Jack can't do it how can
my best friend do it it's impossible no
I was I but you know we had because I
remember even before the show started we
would talk a lot about yeah
the almost like we had these rules and
and a lot of it was there was a don't do
anything that Dave had done but also I
don't I didn't think that was as big a
worry because we both loved cartoons too
much no we were naturally suited to what
we wanted to do wanted to do very silly
strange uh things that that were but but
even when we used to do actual items and
it was the first piece we ever did on
the show which was our was our shot
across the bow yes because Jay would do
the thing where he'd go Oh see it just
real ads from like Sears and robu and
this and fairness that was small town
news from Dave yeah Jay borrowed borrow
I borrowed
it they can have it back they can have
it back he just can't do The Tonight
Show you know but he can have it back
anytime he wants he can have it anytime
he wants I like doing da invented
headlines all of a
sudden so he did no no no no you do it I
you do it cuz I'm you know whatever um
but whatever we did a fake one of those
where we would just hold up I don't even
remember what they were but we had
everybody writing them and they were
some of them were so dark but they were
hilarious we would alter these ads and
then it would be you know like I would
say we we've talked about this but we
would say cuz I always loved this bit
and um it would say look at this it's
for nice trampoline that kids can play
on but look at over here and in the
corner there'd be a Charles Manson yeah
saying what's it there for yeah and I'd
be like what's Charles man and always
Charles Manson saying something like
it's my favorite trampoline to murder to
whatever it didn't make they were they
were much funnier than that but it was
and then I would be incredulous and well
you and you would guys would always say
you can't make this stuff up make this
stuff up and if you wanted to and then
I'd go too far if you wanted to and had
writers and a graphics Department yeah
right that was the first um first bit we
did and yeah Lauren Lauren really wanted
that on the first show yeah Lauren
Michaels yes laen Michaels from
television and uh and now from
everything um every I'm everywhere I
make clothes now I'm under hi everybody
I'm right here do you have my leisure
suit Conan do you really want to go with
those sneakers he's
um uh I want to take people back in time
to when I first met you would be 1988
the very beginning of 1988 yeah my
writing partner Greg Daniels and I get
hired to come in to work at SNL were
petrified and I remembered finding there
was just this natural thing where I
gravitated towards you and Bob Odenkirk
yeah uh and uh who's now the jlan Von
Dam
I always knew knew always knew that guy
that guy's gonna that guy's gonna have a
John Wick franchise he's gonna have a
stunt man and yeah um but and then we
started uh naturally just all goofing
around together and then uh I think the
thing that was really life-changing for
me is that you a few years before had
done a show in Chicago a stage show and
the writer strike hit and you and Odin
Kirk were talking yes and you said hey
um we might go to Chicago and do a stage
show with sketches that are too weird to
get on SNL right and then you guys asked
me would I come along I was thrilled I
had a 1973 uh Plymouth Valiant that I I
flew to uh la which is where my car was
and I drove my car to Chicago by myself
uh and the car kept overheating like
it's that old movie uh duel it would
overheat on hills and I would have to
pull it over and by the way I think he
was driving also a similar car was um I
would pull it over and the steam would
and then it would calm down and I had
things of water and I would pour them in
and I made my way to Chicago and that
was where yeah that changed that changed
things for me because I thought I love
this I love working with these guys I
love that we're doing a stage show in
Chicago I loved that summer the whole
thing was magical yeah no I I still feel
like my years in Chicago before I even
got Saturday Night Live or like
professionally in some way the happiest
years of my whole life just being in
total control of your own show and and
just I love the city of Chicago too
obviously but um but yeah no we loved
you so much uh when we met you you're
such a funny guy and uh Bob and I like I
thought I was going to get fired from
Saturday Night Live in the summer of
86 I I did one season at SNL and I just
barely hung on and uh Franken called me
over the summer Frank it's not looking
good I don't know you know just a lot of
people are you know it was a hard year
and you know who really was funny swore
it
swell remember what he wrote anyway I'm
sorry it's just yeah so but then Lauren
called me in at the last minute but but
Odin Kirk and I were developing a sketch
show that summer we were going to call
it
sketchcomic in 1988 yeah and we would
all stand there in the year 2000 and
then we would make these insane
predictions about what was then the
future yes it was all based on this
Jetson's Concept in the 60s that 60s
kids grew up with which was the idea
that like the space age is coming
like by the year 2000 they had so much
Mystique to it and then as we got closer
to the year 2000 it was quite clear that
was going to be well then the
awward was doing it still I mean late
night we never late night despite
everyone's predictions yes kept going
and going and going and lasted and
actually started you know worked and
then we were doing it and then it is the
year 2000 and the year 20 and then and
we kept thinking do we need to change
like in the distant future and I and I
said no it's just got to still be in the
year 2000 and in 2006 I'm like it's time
to look into the future all the way to
the year
2000 uh but it's a good problem to have
um yeah I uh so so we did that show
together and we work together a lot at
SNL and the one thing I remembered is
feeling very much like you could finish
my sentence and I could finish your
sentence
I only connected with a few writers in
my years there like really connected in
different ways Dana was one of them Dana
Carvey and not as a performer almost
because I love doing silly voices and
Impressions and so we wrote a lot of
like musical impression kind of sketches
like mlin and U Regis and things like
that and Johnny Carson and then um Conan
I connected in a completely different
way just we had this um we just saw
people from a distance and we were able
to kind of like reduce everybody to a
cartoon yes yeah I was because over the
years people have said your biggest
comedic influences and it's so cool to
say well I would watch uh you know old
clips of Ernie Kovac and that really and
it's like no it's not true nothing
inspired me more than Warner Brothers
cartoons oh God and uh so that the idea
of anything can be alive which then
Paul Ruben so brilliantly in peewee's
playhous oh yeah the idea that
everything chair is Cherry um but but
anthropomorph this is a thing I've done
a thousand times in comedy and I can
never pronounce it anthropomorphize
anthropomorphize and um the uh even the
word anthropomorphize can be a
character hi I'm
anthropomorphizing what's up
anthropomorph isy uh but but but you why
are you so damn hard to pronounce that's
just me I
guess